dès que libé d'eau bénite et vianney
chez vous l'aimez bien elle aime
toujours autant
ouais et alors on est où là c'est bien
beau de merde et chemise à manches
courtes mais on en est au niveau des
meubles un bon jour avec le wet veut
toujours à la même heure 1
c'est bon ça fait combien de temps on
doit faire ou non tu peux nous lire un
peu presque trois ans non sur la vie des
ghosts presque une année bissextile
c'est fort aimé lui cela dorment ils
adorent puissiez à nicolas pernikoff or
lui pour ceux qui ne le connaissaient
pas numéro 3 de france télé pendant des
années y'a pas un programme qui passait
son kiff ours à lunettes de dont nicolas
pernikoff et je le redis à france
télévisions à l'époque c'était ave
nicolas pernikoff je rappelle louis
cyrille j'ai peut-être prime time doit
non même nathalie vous connaissiez
nicolas pernikoff quand même quand vous
connaissez pas vous n'avez jamais
pouvoir serrer longtemps c'était à
combien il ya une bonne dizaine d'années
mais ces bonnes mais voilà
[Rires]